Hi, Andrea, how are you?
Hello, I'm fine, thanks.
How's it going?
It's going well.
And how was your long weekend?
It was good. The weather was bad, but it was good.
Yeah.
Was it too hot, too cold?
No, it was raining the whole time, and it was very cold.
Okay.
But then yesterday, late in the day, it got better. Suddenly the sun came out and it went up to 72, so that was really good. So it kind of salvaged the end of the weekend.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, even I was, I went to do a trip with my August team.
So this weekend and it was nice connecting with them and getting to know each other well.
Mhm.
That's good.
We did some bonfire and some BBQ.
Oh, that's fun.
Yeah, it was nice up in the mountains. So it was a bit far, but it was nice. We can get away.
Yeah.
Oh.
That's good to get away, yeah.
Damn right.
All right, so how are things going with something?
Um, let's wait for Kris. He's going to be joining the call.
OK. Thank you.
Haight.
Oh, come in, come in. That's fine. Thank you. That's fine. Do I need to sign? Okay, thank you.
Just got a package.
Hello, Kris.
Hello, how you doing?
I'm doing good. How about you?
Very good. Thank you. Excuse me.
Pre.
It's been quite a long time we connected.
Indeed. Excuse me.
Mm.
So how is it going?
Uh, it's going alright, you know, busy as always.
OK, and how are things so with some rain?
I think generally pretty good.
Okay, great. Any feedback you would like to share? Any suggestion?
Um, of late I have found her time entries to be a little...
Kurt, not as descriptive as they, as they.
Once were, I've commented on them to her a couple of times, so I think she's been working on it, so I don't think it's necessarily a significant issue.
Okay.
Okay, okay, sure. I will share the feedback with her as well. So, and we'll keep a track on that as well.
Excuse me.
Ohh, what else?
That's all I've got.
Okay, great. And Kris, I also sent you, I re-triggered the surveys for the month of March and April. So please take out some time to fill out those surveys for some rain.
Yep.
It should be in your inbox. So let's quickly, let me share my screen and let's go through the presentation then.
Excuse me.
Yep.
Okay, let me know once you are able to see my screen.
I can see it.
Okay, great. Once again, welcome to our bi-weekly business review. This is for the last two weeks, starting May 11th till May 22nd.
Agenda would be the same. There's no change. Check in, highlights, action tracker, performance analysis, voice of a customer, way forward and recap.
And we already talked about how things are moving. And thank you for sharing the feedback and we really appreciate it.
The highlights, we have been getting good feedback for some green. She's the pleasant, reliable. We also received appreciation for her strong ticket notes. But as you mentioned that.
There are some things that she needs to work on, so I will make sure that that is addressed.
And we also talked about something to reach out to Kris sooner whenever she's stuck on any issue. And regarding the KPI reporting task, I'm working with the Caseya products board and I have a meeting scheduled with Ryan Kennick this Friday. And we'll get some traction on that.
And somebody is on PTO for this week and will be coming back on Monday and the CSAT I already mentioned that I have already resent the service for the month of March and April.
Moving on to the action tracker, so building KP reports, that is again already in progress. There are a few things we are dependent on to see our support, so I have already opened a ticket with them and I'm working with them proactively.
And level up to advances to administrative, that is again in progress and we are expecting some rain to complete it by the mid of June.
Yeah.
These are the ITBD recommended KPIs we already discussed. I'm going to skip this for now.
Let's jump it to the performance analysis. This is her utilization for the last two weeks. So it had been up 67% on average. So from May 11 to 15, it was around 70%. And then in the last week, it was 63%.
Any question on this one?
Nope.
Key.
Moving on to her ticket data, she worked on 87 tickets and closed 31 of them. That makes her ticket closure at 39 percent.
And ticket volume had been pretty much consistent in those weeks.
Ben.
And...
way forward, some way into proactively reach out, as I mentioned earlier as well, to Kris whenever she's stuck on an issue. And we'll continue to support her to close more tickets and make her ticket notes more detailed, more descriptive.
Yep. She has seemed to be generally better at escalating, I will say. I don't, you know, there was one ticket that neither she nor Nick seemed to escalate very quickly for some reason, but other than that one anomaly, I think she's been better.
Mhm.
I mean, Andrea, you haven't seen stuff.
hang up and go on forever that often recently, right? I think that problem is pretty well taken care of itself now.
Oh, no.
No.
And I would mention if I saw something sitting that needed to be addressed, I often do mention like, hey, what's going on with this?
Yeah, like I said, there was only one recently. I forget what it was offhand, but oh, is that VPN thing for an ABI client? I mean, we spent 12 hours on something that should have taken 45 minutes. Somehow it didn't get escalated, but it should have. But I mean, that's a one-off, so not.
Right.
Yeah.
Not really a huge deal, but yeah, she has seemed much better at that, I think.
Okay.
Thank you for sharing the feedback, Kris. Yep.
In all fairness with that one, I believe that was one that had actually been started by a different tech and got handed off to her. So I think she kind of came in midway maybe and wasn't clear on all that had been done.
The.
Yeah, I do think it probably is the other tech who really should have escalated better and sooner, but again, it's just...
Yeah, because she took it over when they went on vacation and then she kind of came in the middle of it and it said, reach out to this client and work with them. So she said, oh, okay, I will. And then, you know, it really was a lot simpler than that.
Yeah, yeah.
S.
But again, either way, it was this, it was a one-off situation, so I'm not.
Right, right. Oh, she does a good job.
And...
Deal either way.
Okay, yeah.
Thank you, Kris, for sharing. I will definitely make sure that it doesn't happen again.
And moving on to the Build It Live 2026.
Yes, are you planning to attend the billet this year?
No, I am going to be in Europe.
That time.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
I don't know why they're having this the first week of August. That is like the hottest week of the year in New Jersey. Yeah, I just, I, somebody just wasn't paying attention to the weather forecast. And that week in New Jersey, there's nobody there. Everybody's at the beach. It's just, it's just prime vacation time.
Yeah, you mentioned that.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I...
Okay.
Yeah.
Yeah, I will definitely share the feedback with them to ensure that.
I...
Hoh.
At least it, at least it's not Vegas, but...
I used to live there. I know what it's like. It's very, very hot. I used to come up here because it was so hot there.
Yeah.
Okay. All right, so this is the AIMI design, few services that we offer, and this is the Team GPS, our in-house tool. And that's it. Any other feedback, Kris, Andrea, you would like to share?
I think I'm good.
Sameer.
All right, Kris, and do check your inbox for the surveys that I resent for something for the month of March and April. Okay, okay, thank you. Thank you so much.
And.
I just sent them.
I just sent them, yep.
All right, so thank you for joining the call today and have a wonderful rest of the day and week.
So I want to, before we separate, I want to, the next call will be on the 8th. Is that what we're scheduled to be the 8th?
Yep.
Two weeks from today.
That would be on, yeah, 8th, yes.
Okay, okay. Just checking.
Okay, okay. All right, so thank you and have a wonderful day. Bye-bye.
Alright, thank you.
Thank you, you too. Bye.
Thank you. Bye-bye.